welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Whitney van laningham and with the
Oscars fast approaching I wanted to
break down one of the animated nominees
for Best Picture Golden Globe
award-winning Guillermo del Toros
Pinocchio although the story of the
little wooden puppet who longed to
become a real boy has been adapted and
retold many times I was most familiar
with the 1940s Disney movie before
checking out del Toro's reimagination
unlike that version however this
iteration of Pinocchio isn't for
children this story beautifully
incorporates themes of Life Death and
love while simultaneously giving the
finger to Fascism so today I'm breaking
down all the Easter eggs and details you
might have missed in Guillermo del
Toro's Pinocchio Pinocchio was
originally written in the early 1800s by
an Italian author named Carlo colotti
and went on to become the third most
translated book in the world as well as
the first piece of Italian children's
literature to achieve International Fame
at the time of its writing the
industrialization of Italy called for a
story that encouraged its readers to
adhere to structure and become part of
the reliable labor force Galati often
used Pinocchio's Adventures to chastise
him and therefore his readers from
engaging in too much frivolous fun and
rejecting responsibility the 1940s
Disney version had a similar message as
Pinocchio wanted to become a real boy he
had to learn to become Brave honest and
unselfish now I don't know about you
guys but after watching Pinocchio when I
was a kid I was terrified that if I
goofed off I'd be taken to an island and
forced to get drunk and smoke cigars and
turn into a donkey while my mom was
trapped inside of a whale but Del Toro
saw a different vision for this movie
deciding to fill up the narrative that
children must be well behaved to be seen
as real instead of using this beloved
character to show the viewer that they
need to change themselves in order to be
accepted Del Toro told den of geek in an
interview that quote I always wanted to
make it about Disobedience and not
changing in a way I knew I wanted him to
stand his own ground he also said he
celebrates Disobedience as a virtue and
celebrates not being changed to be loved
del Toro's Pinocchio is less about
Pinocchio's fatal flaws and more about
the flawed way that the world tends to
operate he also added in the interview
that the movie is not about Pinocchio
learning to be a real boy but but Japan
learning to be a real father the film
opens up with an image of a pinecart not
only does Pinocchio mean pine nut in the
Tuscan Italian dialect but the Pinecone
itself becomes a common symbol
throughout the story historically pine
cones have been known to be symbols of
immortality spirituality and
regeneration del Toro's Pinocchio plays
with each of these themes both in
metaphor and in the literal sense with
Pinocchio being an immortal being
throughout story during the opening act
set in 1916 Italy Geppetto urges his son
Carlo to find the perfect pine cone
tossing out an imperfect cone this is
the first we see of Geppetto's own flaw
of being a perfectionist and his Arc
throughout the film has him learning to
accept Pinocchio for the imperfect boy
that he is Carlo on the other hand is
seemingly the perfect son if you didn't
catch it yet he's named after
Pinocchio's original author Carlo pilati
as we start to get a glimpse at Carlo
and Geppetto's life together in the
opening member my son we can see three
prominent puppets that foreshadow
characters later on in the film The
Monkey for spazatura the night for the
podesta and the fox for the tricky
charlatan count Volpe if you take take a
look at Geppetto's woodworking station
the window behind it looks pretty
similar to the window at giles's Art
station in Del Toro is the shape of
water Geppetto is tasked with building a
new crucifix for the local church and of
course Carlo is by his side for the
initial build their version of Christ on
the cross looks just like the crucifix
from del Toro's 2001 film The Devil's
Backbone if you look closely at the
stained glass windows you can also see
Easter eggs for del Toro's Pan's
Labyrinth the Fawn and The Pale Man Del
Toro actually views Pinocchio as part of
a Trilogy with these films as they're
all films that explore dark Fantastical
childhood adventures during wartime the
stained glass windows also feature a
continuation of Pinecone Motif and a
falling Dove shaped like a bomb
foreshadowing the bombing at the end of
this scene between the stained glass we
can also see an illustration of an angel
that looks like the Wood Sprite we meet
later on in the film unfortunately Carlo
was killed when austro-hungarian forces
flying above Italy drop a bomb on their
Church the way that this bomb is
featured and dropped is modeled after
the bombing scene of the Devil's
Backbone in earlier drafts of the movie
Carlo was instead killed by by a firing
squad but due to pacing Del Toro swapped
this death with a bombing Geppetto is
nearly destroyed by his grief and plants
the pine cone his son was holding when
he died near his carefully tended Brave
at the bottom of the tombstone you can
see two rabbits on either side of a pine
cone later in the film we learned that
rabbits escort your soul into the
Afterlife the story fast forwards
roughly 20-ish years to the late 30s
early 40s where Benito Mussolini's
fascist rule has warped Italy a colorful
mural that previously advertised a
Bountiful Harvest Festival now has been
painted over in black and white with the
fascist slogan believe obey fight the
towers blacksmith who once admired
Geppetto's fatherhood is now the town's
podesta essentially a mayor with full
authoritarian power this Bleak reality
reflects Geppetto's internal despair
without his son and sets up a world
begging to be disobeyed Sebastian J
Cricket makes his home in the pine tree
grown some Carlos Pine count inside he
hangs a portrait of Arthur schopenhauer
a pessimistic German philosopher
Sebastian J crickets shares
schopenhauer's philosophy that life is
filled with inescapable pain and the
best that one can do is simply reduce it
in a drunken rage Geppetto carves a
wooden boy out of the tree here we see
the pine cones immortality Harlow's
death inspired his father to plant the
seed which grew into a pine tree which
became Sebastian J Cricket's home which
was then cut down and made into a puppet
as Geppetto himself tells Carlo in the
movie when one life is lost another must
grow in a Netflix promo video Del Toro
tells us that Pinocchio's janky look was
intentional saying we made him
asymmetrical because Geppetto carves him
when he's drunk and one of the ideas is
that he starts with the ear and his hair
and he's really careful with that and
then he goes ah and kind of just
finishes him quick taking care of
yourself is important so good thing
geology makes it easy to do theology is
a 16-time award-winning personalized
skincare company recognized in hypey's
birdie Men's Health Esquire and ask men
grooming Awards with over 6 000 5 Star
reviews just take a quick 30 second
diagnostic quiz and geology will create
a simple and effective skin care or hair
care routine customized just for you
with ingredients that our dermatologist
tested proven to work and personalized
to your needs for Hair Care geology's
got strengthening shampoo and
conditioner and co-wash which will
transform your routine and deliver the
best hair of your life it extends the
time between washes and replaces the
need for so many products you wash your
hair less and save money more they also
offer body washes and deodorants that
are free of harsh ingredients and smell
great for skin care they have you
covered from all angles bite acne reduce
oiliness prevent wrinkles combat dark or
puffy under eyes have smoother hydrated
skin and Target signs of aging their
daily personalized skincare routine
comes with two face washes morning face
cream retinol night cream and eye cream
and right now for a limited time you can
get a five piece trial set for only 15
if you use code Rockstar 70 at checkout
that's over a hundred and fifty dollars
of product for just 15 bucks on top of
that you can take an additional 30 bonus
offer on one of their brand new skin
hair or body products of your choice
when you add it to your trial to get
started just click the link in the
description one of my favorite creature
designs from this movie is that of the
Wood Sprite in her Phantom trail of
glowing eyeballs putting eyeballs where
they're definitely not supposed to be is
Guillermo del Toro special the Wood
Sprite and her sister death are no
different their character designs are
inspired by the Angel of Death from
Hellboy whose wings were also decked out
in eyeballs the wood sprite's design is
also a nod to the biblical description
of angels while death draws her design
from the mythical Chimera when Pinocchio
walks into the church for the first time
you'll notice that Jesus's left arm was
destroyed when the bomb hits towards the
end of the film after surviving his
encounter with a dogfish Pinocchio also
loses his left arm symbolizing the
sacrifice he made for his father after
scaring the [__] out of a bunch of
Catholics a priest the podesta and his
son candle wick show up at Geppetto's
home demanding answers Geppetto
instructs his son to warm his feet by
the fire but Pinocchio gets carried away
accidentally burning his feet off this
is actually a reference to a really dark
scene in Carlo colotti's book where
Pinocchio is too exhausted to realize
that his feet have burned to Ash
candlelick's name is another direct pull
from the original fairy tale his name
Lucy ignolo translates to lampwick or
Candlewick in Italian in Disney's
adaptation the hair character goes by
lamp with Father and Son head into town
the next day where they see a sign for
the circus and instead of following his
father's orders and heading to school
Pinocchio ends up joining the carnival
the way that this Carnival's set up also
reminds me of scenes from del Toro's
nightmare Allen which was clearly an
inspiration for the design of this world
its owner Volpe is a conniving trickster
much like his characters Disney
counterpart Honest John the swindling
Fox his name is Italian for Fox he
carries a cane topped with a fox head
and his hair even looks sort of like box
ears and check out the nose on this guy
that thing is so long the audience can
tell instantly that this dude is a liar
mclierson in addition to being an
adaptation of the fox Volpe also
incorporates the characteristics and
role of the Ring Master most upsettingly
Volpe treats spasitura like trash
literally the name spazitura is Italian
for garbage and it's clear from the
three severed monkey heads hanging on
volpei's trailer wall that spasitura
wasn't his first primate assistant
Sebastian J Cricket tries to tell
Pinocchio not to go with count Volpe but
his curiosity gets the better of him
check out the cricket talking to
Pinocchio on his shoulder for scenes
like this where Sebastian needed to
speak to his wooden friend up close the
animators created extra large models of
Pinocchio's head with normal sized
Cricket puppets to film their
conversations likewise Sebastian was
made large for certain scenes while
Pinocchio was made smaller an artist
Chris grimley's initial drawings for
these characters he made notes that
although Pinocchio's head could change
sizes it could never change shape to
maintain his wooden appearance Pope
introduces his puppets to Pinocchio El
diavolo colombina and punchinello
obviously the first is a caricature of
the Devil palumbina is a stock character
in many of Italy's Comedia Del Arte AKA
Italian comedy theater Productions often
depicted as a sex worker a slave or a
wife mistress panchonello is an equally
famous character in Italian Puppet
Theater his first appearance dating all
the way back to the 1660s he's usually
shown as a short Stout clown who behaves
ridiculously and was the inspiration
behind punch of the Punch and Judy
puppet series after being chastised by
his father for performing in the circus
instead of going to school Nokia was hit
by the podesta car in the afterlife four
rabbits carry his coffin and when they
go to punch his ticket the card punching
system is the same as the one from the
shape of water when Pinocchio visits
death you'll notice that her serpent
tail is designed to look like the scales
of a Pinecone also her use of sand
hourglasses is a nod to the one used by
Ophelia as she faced Down The Pale Man
in Pan's Labyrinth death explains the
Pinocchio cannot die and therefore can
never be a real boy the humanity is
special because each of our lives are
fleeting after Geppetto says some harsh
words to his reborn wooden Sun Pinocchio
decides to run away with the carnival to
make money to send to his father he
leaves a note with a smiling son for his
dad to find and traps Sebastian J
Prickett in a glass on top of it placing
a hammer Atop The Glass to prevent his
bug friend from stopping him although
Sebastian manages to break free he gets
squished by the Hammer's handle this is
another nod to the original Pinocchio
story where Pinocchio actually kills the
cricket with a hammer and a fit of rage
don't worry he lives a long buggy life
in this movie though Pinocchio travels
across Italy performing in support of
ilduche AKA Mussolini Geppetto and
Sebastian follow them always just a city
or two behind until Geppetto manages to
convince a fisherman to sail him to his
son but he and Sebastian are both
swallowed by a monstrous Dogfish the
book's five-story large Dogfish has been
interpreted and adapted in many
different ways sometimes it's a shark or
an orca or a sperm whale like Disney's
monstro del Toro's Dogfish incorporates
elements of a grotesque anglerfish when
Mussolini himself arrives at the
carnival to catch a show he pulls up in
a long red car just like this classic
scene from Tom and Jerry and Boots the
cat rolls up in the same style vehicle
this long-ass car gag has appeared
countless times in cartoons but Tom and
Jerry's my favorite this car's
ridiculous size juxtaposed with the
dictator's stature spoofs on Mussolini's
ego and pokes fun at his regime
embracing the authoritarian Superman
Pinocchio performs a rendition of his
usual act with a Twist the entire song
is about poop and you know this dictator
sucks because only fascists refused to
giggle at fart jokes the poster of
Mussolini that the puppets defaced now
reads sua as gramenza puzzolini which is
a play on the phrase
Enzo which means his Excellency in
Italian Cuzo translates to stinky so
here Pinocchio is basically calling him
his poopy Excellency mussmelini after
being shot by one of the dictator's men
Pinocchio awakens from Death in the back
of the bestest truck carrying other
future soldiers to training camp the
boys dormitories are modeled to look
just like the ones from The Devil's
Backbone candle Wick's Rebellion against
his father and the subsequent attack on
the center allowed Pinocchio to escape
and spasitura rescues him before he's
burned alive at the stake by count Volpe
Pinocchio and spazatura flee to Sea
where they're also swallowed by the
dogfish and reunited with Geppetto and
Sebastian the four are able to escape
the belly of the Beast to the monsters
blowhole in the Disney version they
escape through monstro's mouth by making
him sneeze and unlike Disney's Pinocchio
del Toro's wooden boy sets off a mine in
the dogfish's mouth this time when
Pinocchio visits death she informs him
that if he wants to save his father from
drowning he must become a real boy and
will die himself Pinocchio sacrifices
his life for his father this time when
the Wood Sprite appears Sebastian uses
one wish to bring japetto's son back to
life when Pinocchio wakes up from Death
once again his papa admits that he
finally accepts him for exactly the way
he is although Pinocchio lives forever
he has to watch each of his loved ones
die before him when Sebastian J Cricket
passes on he places him inside of a
matchbox and stores the matchbox inside
of his wooden body close to his heart
the whole where Pinocchio places his
body is the same hole that Sebastian
first entered his lovely tree home the
final shot of the movie is that of a
single pine cone falling from a branch
symbolizing another death that leads to
a new beginning follow me on Instagram
and Twitter at whitneypuppy follow new
Rockstar subscribe to new rockstars for
more analysis of everything you love and
thanks for watching bye
foreign
[Music]